A FULL REPORT THERE.
NOW LET’S GET DEEPER.
ARIZONA AND MONTANA ARE SUING
TO BLOCK PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
RULES WHICH WOULD DRAMATICALLY
NARROW THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ICE AGENTS ARREST OR
DEPORT.
THE STATES ARGUE THE POLICIES
WOULD HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES AND IT IS LIKELY
ALREADY HAPPENING.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING THAT ICE DATA SHOW
THE NUMBER OF ARRESTS UNDER
BIDEN ALREADY FELL BY MORE THAN
60% LAST MONTH COMPARED WITH
THE LAST THREE MONTHS OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THE DEPORTATIONS FELL BY NEARLY
THAT SAME AMOUNT.
JOINING ME NOW FROM ONE OF THE
STATES THE TWO THAT ARE SUING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
MONTANA ATTORNEY GENERAL AUSTIN
KNUTSON, GOOD TO SEE YOU TODAY.
TELL ME EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING POTENTIALLY ALREADY
AND WHY.
>> WE FILED THE LAWSUIT IN THE
FEDERAL COURT, HARRIS, ASKING
THE COURT TO STOP THIS ORDER
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THIS IS DEVASTATING FOR STATES
LIKE ARIZONA AND YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING WHY IS MONTANA JOINING
THIS LAWSUIT?
IT’S DEVASTATING FOR STATES
LIKE MONTANA, TOO AND PUT THE
WHOLE COUNTRY IN DANGER.
VIOLENT CRIME IN MONTANA HAS
RISEN BY 48% SINCE 2013, HARRIS.
AND WE KNOW THIS IS FROM
MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS SMUGGLING
DRUGS UP THROUGH THE UNSECURED
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT WILL KEEP GETTING WORSE
UNDER THIS MORATORIUM ORDER
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THAT’S WHY WE’VE SUED.
>> Harris: LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
ATTORNEY GENERAL, YOU KNOW,
WHERE DO THEY GO IF ICE AGENTS
ARE NOT ARRESTING THEM?
AND I ASK THAT BECAUSE I KNOW
FROM LOOKING AT MONTANA’S
RECORDS THAT METH IS SUCH A
HUGE PROBLEM AND YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE DRUG CARTELS
BRINGING IT INTO YOUR STATE.
YOU ARE AWARE THESE PEOPLE ARE
THERE.
WHAT IMPACT DOES IT HAVE IF
BIDEN DOESN’T HAVE ICE AGENTS
ROUNDING THEM UP?
WHERE ARE THEY?
>> IT HAS A HUGE IMPACT.
THEY ARE COMING IN THE COUNTRY
AND SPREADING OUT TO THE
INTERIOR.
I THINK PEOPLE MISTAKENLY THINK
IT’S JUST A SOUTHERN STATE
PROBLEM.
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA.
IT CERTAINLY IS BUT ALSO A
NORTHERN STATE PROBLEM.
LIKE I SAID, OUR LARGEST CITY
HERE IN MONTANA, BILLINGS,
MONTANA, 88% INCREASE IN
METH-RELATED CRIME IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
VIOLENT CRIME HAS SPIKED
DRAMATICALLY IN MONTANA AND I
CAN TELL YOU THIS IS 100% TIED
TO THE DRUG CARTELS IN MEXICO
AND FROM ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
THAT ARE SMUGGLING THESE
POISONS INTO OUR STATE.
THIS IS A HUGE CRISIS FOR A
STATE LIKE MONTANA AND THAT’S
WHY WE’VE JUMPED IN THIS THING.
>> Harris: HOW IS YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABLE TO HANDLE THAT?
IT SOUNDS LIKE A BIG JOB.
88 PERCENT IN ANY CRIME
CATEGORY WOULD BE A LOT.
>> WE’RE A VERY LARGE STATE
GEOGRAPHICALLY BUT A SMALL
STATE POPULATION-WISE.
JUST OVER A MILLION PEOPLE.
WE DON’T HAVE A LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEY’RE
COVERING A HUGE GEOGRAPHIC
TERRITORY.
MONTANA HIGHWAY PATROL PATROL
THOSE AND THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
HIGHWAY.
THERE ARE ONLY 200 OF THEM.
THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
STRETCHED ABSOLUTELY THIN.
THERE IS NO WAY WE CAN KEEP UP
WITH THIS.
>> Harris: TELL ME QUICKLY WHAT
SOME OF THE CITIZENS ARE
TELLING YOU.
YOU ARE AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL’S OFFICE AND PEOPLE
WILL CALL AND SAY THIS IS WHAT
I’M EXPERIENCING WITH A SPIKE
OF 88% IN CRIME THAT YOU SAY IS
TIED TO WHAT IS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
IT MAKES SENSE.
METHAMPHETAMINE COMING FROM THE
CARTELS.
>> LOOK, I’M FROM A VERY RURAL
PART OF THE STATE.
A FORMER PROSECUTOR.
I DEALT WITH THIS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
WE SEE IT ALL OVER THE STATE.
IT IS A PROBLEM IN OUR CITIES,
PROBLEM IN OUR COUNTIES, A
PROBLEM IN OUR RURAL AREAS.
PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE THAT.
YOU SEE IT ALL OVER THE STATE
OF MONTANA.
IT IS BY FAR THE NUMBER ONE
THING I HEAR ABOUT.
THE BIGGEST REASON WHY I RAN
FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
FRANKLY THAT’S WHY I TAKE THIS
MOVE FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN SO
SERIOUSLY AND WHY WE JUMPED
INTO THIS LAWSUIT.
IT IS A HUGE DEAL FOR STATES
LIKE MONTANA.
>> Harris: DO YOU ANTICIPATE
MORE STATES WILL JOIN YOU IN
THIS?
>> I DO, YES.
>> Harris: GOT IT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL KNUTSON FROM
THE GREAT STATE OF MONTANA.
WE’LL BRING YOU BACK TO GET THE